Länder entschieden bald Kampfjets zu
liefern ein Zeichen für Gesprächskanäle
ist aber die Verlängerung des
getreideabkommens zwischen der Ukraine
und Russland durch Vermittlung der
Türkei die wiederum stimmt dem
NATO-Beitritt Finnlands zu aber noch
nicht dem NATO-Beitritt Schwedens Waffen
nato-diplomatie welche Strategie führt
zum Frieden darüber spreche ich heute
mit diesen Gästen ich begrüße herzlich
Katherine Clüver ashbook sie ist
deutsch-amerikanische Journalistin und
Politikwissenschaftlerin Sinja Advisor
der Bertelsmannstiftung ich begrüße
Thomas Lundin Deutschland Korrespondent
für die schwedische Tageszeitung svenska
bergplattet und herzlich willkommen
Roman goncarenko er ist ukrainischer
Journalist und Redakteur für Osteuropa
in der Deutschen Welle und der hat vor
einem Jahr seine Familie aus der Ukraine
nach Bonn geholt herzlich willkommen
Erik bonse er ist freier
eu-korrespondant in Brüssel unter
anderem für die tats und Cicero und
betreibt den Block lost in Europe
dieser Entscheidung des Internationalen
Strafgerichtshof Präsident Putin als
Kriegsverbrecher zu sagen oder für seine
Kriegsverbrechen vor allem für die
Deportation der Kinder eben zu
verurteilen was bedeutet das das ist
eine sehr starke symbolische
Entscheidung sie zeigt dass man nicht
ohne Verantwortung so einen Krieg führen
darf wichtiges Detail natürlich putin
wird nicht behaftbefehl gesucht weil er
diesen Krieg begonnen hatte sondern im
wie sie erwähnt haben die Deputation von
Kindern und das ist ein sehr sensibles
und emotionales Thema
ich war jetzt vor einigen Wochen auf der
Münchner Sicherheitskonferenz und ich
habe auch sehr deutlich gespürt vor
allem wie stark dieses Thema
kinderentführungen die Menschen an die
Politiker auch die us-vizepräsidentin
Camera Harris bewegt hat das heißt es
zeigt niemand bleibt ohne Verantwortung
aber natürlich ist es auch klar dass
Boote nicht morgen verhaftet wird wenn
er irgendwo auf Reisen ist natürlich ist
bei manchen die Hoffnung so dass seine
Reisefreiheit jetzt eingeschränkt wird
ich persönlich glaube nicht dass das
passiert ich glaube das auch wenn er
jetzt nach Deutschland kommen sollte und
nach Westeuropa es eine Ausnahme geben
wird weil man sich vielleicht überlegt
die der Preis für mögliche
Friedensverhandlungen oder kriegsstoff
ist vielleicht höher als ähm diesen
Befehl durchzusetzen auf jeden Fall ist
es auch ein Zeichen an seine Elite das
die Ermittlungen in Den Haag die dauern
an und ähm alle sind bekannt also ein
mehr als ein Symbol aber aus dem so dass
man sagt man kann nicht davon ausgehen
dass man ihn natürlich sofort festsetzt
der Internationale Strafgerichtshof ist
von den USA gar nicht anerkannt aber
trotzdem hat Präsident beiden diese
Entscheidung in diesen Haftbefehl zu
erlassen begrüßt wie muss man das denn
eigentlich verstehen ja es ist ganz
interessant zu sehen wie man die
innenpolitische Diskussionen darüber
entbrannt ist wir haben einen
Verteidigungsminister in Nordosten
erlebt in der letzten Woche der gesagt
hat naja wir müssen schauen wie wir mit
Beweismaterialien umgehen denn hinten
schwingt natürlich mit wenn man jetzt
einen präsidenzfall setzt und sich sehr
engagiert was den Internationalen
Gerichtshof angeht wo eben die USA kein
Partnerland ist welche Auswirkungen hat
das vielleicht längerfristig für die USA
und für rechtsstellungen und der USA das
auch das hat also für Gesprächsstoff
innerhalb der amerikanischen Regierung
gesagt Präsident beiden selber und die
Vizepräsidentin Kamera Harris das war
wirklich eine sehr bewegte Rede in
München die haben wiederum gesagt ganz
klar und der Außenminister auch der
russische Staatspräsident hat
Kriegsverbrechen begangen und da sind
ist natürlich noch darüber
hinausgegangen über die Situation der
Kinder aber das ist natürlich auch ein
Signal an den globalen Süden wiederum
denn wie wir sehen die westliche
Koalition ringt immer noch darum ihre
eigene Koalition zu erweitern und das
nicht über das Thema
souveränitätsverletzungen zu machen oder
andere menschenrechtsvergehen sondern so
zu thematisieren ist natürlich auch ein
Politikum wenn es darum geht wer stützt
dem Westen in der erweiterten Welt den
Rücken okay
wird wo das in der EU aufgefasst das ist
diesen Haftbefehl geben soll also in der
EU in Brüssel wurde es ja positiv
aufgenommen die Europäische Union bemüht
sich ja seit einiger Zeit also
Kriegsverbrechen aufzuklären bzw zu
identifizieren Beweise zusammen und dann
auch die Verantwortlichen vor Gericht zu
bringen das wird auch Thema beim Treffen
der Außenminister am Montag wieder sein
Frau bärburg hat dann eine
Eigeninitiative für sondertributional
und da geht's schon los also das ist
eine gewisse
Konkurrenz einerseits zwischen dem ICC
dem international starke Gerichtshof in
Den Haag und der Überlegung in Brüssel
da müsste was Eigenes aufziehen um eben
auch ein Angriffskrieg zum Beispiel
zu bestrafen zu können das nächste
Problem ist aber dass man das Thema
kinderdeportation überhaupt nicht auf
dem Schirm hat in Brüssel bisher das war
eigentlich noch in den Diskussionen kein
Thema auch in den Vorbereitungen jetzt
im Außenminister treffen bisher hat man
meistens von Butcher gesprochen wenn es
um Kriegsverbrechen ging das hat mich
ein wenig überrascht und das Timing
macht mich auch sehr nachdenklich denn
ja zum einen direkt also wenige Tage vor
dem Besuch von von Ski in Moskau dem
chinesischen Staatspräsidenten ist das
ein Signal sozusagen ist das ein ein
Gegenschlag und die andere Frage ist sie
hatten es auch angesprochen werden damit
nicht Verhandlungen eigentlich per se
unmöglich gemacht ist das nicht
sozusagen auch ein Schlag gegen all jene
die auch in Europa jetzt darüber
nachdenken dass man doch eine
gesprächslösung oder ein zumindest ein
gesprächskanal braucht kann Kanzler
Scholz überhaupt noch zu starkes Symbol
ist oder Intervall ist dann einfach
eigentlich unmöglich ist dass Herr Putin
in ein anderes Land fährt wo er dann
eigentlich verhaftet werden müsste naja
er kann er kann sicherlich noch einige
Länder reisen aber kann man mit ihm denn
noch sprechen wenn man sagt er ist ein
Kriegsverbrecher er gehört hinter Gitter
kann Herr Scholz ihnen noch einfach so
anrufen und das ist für meine Begriff
ein fatales Signal wenn wir damit die
Möglichkeit zu Gesprächen verbauen wie
wird es in Schweden gesehen war das eine
Nachricht das war gab ja so viele
Nachrichten in dieser Woche die um die
NATO-Beitritt darüber reden wir gleich
aber jetzt noch mal diese Frage
international ich glaube das ist
wirklich eine ein Signale eine Symbol
symbolhafte Entscheidung das ist sehr
wichtig materiell wird es natürlich
darum gehen was vorhin sicher Gerichten
Mediziner vor Ort Kriminalisten vor Ort
ermitteln für die Zukunft
irgendwann werden diese Leute zu
Rechenschaft gezogen werden können ich
glaube auch nicht das ist ein fatale
Signales wie sie sagen dass man jetzt
mit Putin nicht verhandeln wird können
natürlich wird man das tun das wird aber
in Jahren so schätze ich das sein wird
man verhandeln können wenn es um eine
Lösung geht
nicht Sieg oder Frieden sondern
irgendetwas
dazwischenko ist das dann gerade auch
wichtig sozusagen für die ja für die
Moral innerhalb der Ukraine dass man das
das sozusagen die Moral stärkt und wie
steht es nach über einem Jahr Krieg
eigentlich mit dem mit der Bereitschaft
ja der Ukrainerin und der Ukraine diesen
Krieg weiterzuführen ja das ist ein sehr
wichtiger Punkt und da muss ich wieder
auf die Münchner Konferenz zurückweisen
es gab kurz davor den Menschen wenig
Security report also ein Bericht der
jedes Jahr herausgebracht wird und da
gab es eine Umfrage die wurde Ende 22
durchgeführt und die Zahlen waren so
stark dass sie sogar mich überrascht
haben also man hat gefragt welche Lösung
wäre möglich und ähm um die 90% haben
gesagt wir würden weiter kämpfen auch
wenn Russland jetzt Atomwaffen einsetzen
würde um die 90% sind gegen jegliche
Zugeständnisse an Russland das heißt
auch die Option die immer wieder in
Deutschland diskutiert wird dass man
ganz Russland sich auf die Linie am vor
dem 24 Februar 22 zurückzieht also bevor
die große Offensive begonnen wurde das
heißt es gibt überhaupt Null
Kompromissbereitschaft auch in einem
extremen Fall und wir haben auch eine
ganz klare Botschaft des ukrainischen
Oberbefehlshabers gehört das war im
Herbst als Antwort auf auf die Worte des
amerikanischen Commanders Mark Melle der
gesagt hat vielleicht kommt es jetzt zu
einem Stellungskrieg und vielleicht
kommt irgendwann ein günstiger Zeitpunkt
um zu verhandeln und daraufhin reagierte
der ukrainische general saluschni mit
einer sehr klaren Botschaft das Militär
wird keine Zugeständnisse akzeptieren
und wird weiter kämpfen das war das war
sehr deutlich kommuniziert und die
Stimmung ist bis heute so obwohl man
sieht wie in bachmut wie schwer ist und
es ist ja auch noch nicht entschieden
ist
die Kampf Moral ist natürlich
extrem und wir wohnenswert darauf nur
wird es aber nicht ankommt natürlich
solange die Waffen jetzt wie jetzt
geliefert werden und zunehmend geliefert
werden lässt sich das
können Sicherungen vielleicht werden
absolut also im Moment wo das hier
erschüttert wird das oder vielleicht die
Geduld nicht mehr da ist oder war eine
USA ganz neu isolationistische Politik
an die Macht bringen oder europäischen
Wahlen nächstes Jahr oder die Wahl in
Türkei wir wissen es nicht wie stark ist
denn die Unterstützung aus Schweden auch
gerade für die Waffenlieferung wir haben
jetzt gehört Polen und Slowakei wollen
auch Kampfjets liefern wie Sie die
Position entstehen auch sehr stark
dabei ist auch angefordert schwedische
Kampfjets zu liefern und dieser
jahreskrippen
die laut Experten gerade für Ukraine
optimal einsetzbar werden ich glaube es
gibt kein Widerstand und kein große
Widerstand dagegen in der bevölker
Schweden hat sehr viel Waffen geliefert
liegt aber eher wenn man nur die
waffenzahl sieht und die Milliarden eher
in Mittelfeld aber stark Unterstützung
und dass ich glaube das liegt daran dass
wir vielleicht ein bisschen näher dran
sind am Geschehen als sie in Deutschland
die Ostsee ist ein Spannungsfeld die
Menschen sind beunruhigt nervös
wir kriegen über Internet und Radio
gesagt wo die Schutzräume in Schweden
sind
ich habe bei meinen Ferienort in
Südschweden kleines Dorf 200 Meter weit
weg ein Schutzraum die nächsten paar
Kilometer weg sind fünf sechs
es geht die Parole aus spricht nichts
über irgendetwas was sicherheitsrelevant
sein könnte auch nicht mit Freunden
und dann gab es in dieser Woche diese
Nachricht dass die Türkei die ja erst
immer noch zögerlich war dem
NATO-Beitritt Finnland zustimmen will
aber bei Schweden hat man sich noch
nicht entschieden wie ist diese
Nachricht aufgenommen
große Enttäuschung es war zwar
vielleicht abzusehen aber erdogan hat
einen Ton noch mal verschärft hat gesagt
was die als Terroristen bezeichnen
hauptsächlich Anhänger oder Mitglieder
122 müssen ausgeliefert werden früher
hatte man von 70 gesprochen er sagt zu
lange ist erlaubt ist in Schweden den
Koran zu verbrennen wie vor einigen
Wochen geschehen vor der türkischen
Botschaft in Stockholm wird der
Verhandlungen nicht zustimmen
das ist ein herber Rückschlag für
Schweden aber ich denke auch für die
NATO die lässt sich auf der Nase
herumtanzen muss man sagen das Bild das
ich zeig eine außen was für Putin ein
Geschenk des Himmels ist ist eine
zersplitterte zerstrittene NATO
würde ich gerne jeder will da glaube ich
was zu sagen wie würden sie es bewerten
das Erdogan jetzt gesagt hat Finnland ja
Schweden nein sollte die NATO da
reagieren möchte gerade auch noch mal
eine außenpolitischen großschlägen von
seinen innenpolitischen Problemen
ablenken die derer ja viele sind
natürlich nach dem verheerenden Erdbeben
in der Türkei und Syrien erhält
weiterhin bislang jedenfalls an diesem
wahldatum im Mai Fest selbst wenn nicht
mehr klar ist wer überhaupt jetzt zur
Wahl kommen kann das sind ganze Register
zerstört er hat ganz große
innenpolitische kritische Probleme wo
sie wirklich an den Kragen geht die
Opposition steht auf einmal so stark da
wie wie nie zuvor und das heißt er
versucht aller normaler Art von Herrn
Erdogan
außenpolitisch gegenzusteuern um so ein
paar Ablenkungsmanöver zu starten
dennoch ist das ein ganz handfestes
Problem und für die NATO ich ich sehe es
nicht so
dringend wie sie ich glaube nicht dass
es die NATO an sich schwächt dennoch
muss natürlich wir haben einen großen
NATO Gipfel im Sommer und das ist so
dass Datum zu dem eigentlich also und um
die Präsidentschaftswahl
nach der Präsidentschaftswahl eigentlich
dann Verhandlungen so intensiviert
müssen dass zum Ende des Sommers quasi
zu diesem NATO-Gipfel die NATO wieder
geeinsteht das ist ganz ganz klar die
die tickende Uhr
ich denke auch ähnlich wie mein Kollege
aus Schweden dass das kein Ruhmesblatt
für die NATO ist also das erklärte Ziel
von Herrn Stoltenberg war beide Länder
gleichzeitig aufzunehmen dieses Prinzip
ist gebrochen worden man macht sich von
einem Despoten namens Erdogan abhängig
und lässt sich von ihm erpressen man
lässt die geeinte Front aufbrechen und
Erdogan macht ja zum Teil auch
gemeinsame Sache mit Putin das darf man
ja auch nicht vergessen also die NATO
ist meiner Meinung nach nicht in so
einer starken Position wie sie sich
gerne darstellt gerade gelesen wir in
dem europamagazin politiko auch dass die
NATO genauso wie die Europäische Union
größte Schwierigkeiten hatte Waffen und
Munitionen bereitzustellen für die
Ukraine die Lage ist wirklich auf der
Kippe meiner Meinung nach das ist auch
der Punkt den ich eben machen wollte wir
befinden uns hier an einem Punkt oder
einem Scheideweg der der Geschichte
nicht nur der Ukraine sondern der Welt
Politik wie gesagt der Besuch von sie in
Moskau unterstreicht dass da zwei Blöcke
zusammenkommen das ist also ein neuer
Kalterer
möglicherweise eine Friedensinitiative
von der wir nicht wissen was sie
bedeutet möglicherweise ein kalter Krieg
in diesem Moment kommt dieses Urteil die
Europäische Union bereitet sich darauf
vor mehr Waffen zu liefern weiß aber
jetzt schon dass es nicht ausreichend
wird in bachmund steht
schwierig einfach weil die Produktion
nicht hinterher kommt der Renko wie wie
wie sehen Sie das denn wie wie viel
Hoffnung hatten sie oder wie daran
geknüpft dass Schweden und finden auch
an die NATO kommen wie wichtig ist das
für die Ukraine das ist extrem wichtig
und ich teile auch das was her und Ding
gesagt hat dass Schweden sehr
unglücklich ist ich weiß dass man
unbedingt zusammen mit Finnland
weiterleiten wollte aber andererseits
schauen wir doch auf die Karte es ist
Finnland das eine 1.300 lange Grenze zu
Russland hat und die NATO wird jetzt an
diese Grenze herangehen also russland
hat ein deutlich größeres Problem mit
dem Beitritt von Finnland die Türkei hat
zugestimmt und es ist auch für die
Ukraine ein Signal es war ja immer
wieder dieses Argument auch 2008 damals
auf dem Bukarest Gipfel wo Frau Merkel
und Herr sakrosin nein gesagt haben zu
der Vorbereitung der Ukraine auf eine
NATO-Beitritt damals wie im hier ist es
wir können uns nicht vorstellen dass die
Ukraine also so ein großes Land mit ganz
langer Grenze zu Russland NATO
mitgeliefert wird Finnland wird zeigen
dass es geht und das das bedeutet auch
die Chancen für die Ukraine irgendwann
NATO Mitglied zu werden die steigen
und zu dem was er bei uns gesagt hat
China ich teile dass wir ich glaube dass
wir längst schon im Kalten Krieg sind er
kommt nicht jetzt erst und
natürlich hat China und Russland an
diese beiden Länder haben schon kurz vor
dem kriegsaus kurz und kurz vor dem
Überfall ganz deutlich mit dieser
detaillierter Erklärung zu ihrer
Partnerschaft gezeigt wir stehen
zusammen
china hat immer sich ein bisschen
zurückgenommen und ist nicht nach vorne
gegangen hat diese diese Allianz oder
Partnerschaft wie auch immer man das
nennt nicht nach vorne herausgestellt
aber im Hintergrund bei der Abstimmung
im UN-Sicherheitsrat hat sich China
immer auf die russische Seite gestellt
und wenn wir uns diesen Visite diesen
Besuch anschauen das ist ein
Staatsbesuch ein Staatsbesuch und die
Symbolik die jetzt gerade gestern vor
diesem Besuch passiert ist also nämlich
Putins besucht auf der Krim und dann
wurde
auf den Tag genau chinesische Besucher
terminiert ist weil sie zwei Tage nach
der diesem Jahrestag und dann erreichst
Putin noch nach mariopol in die vor
kurzem besetzten Gebiete und dann am
nächsten Tag trifft er sich mit dem
chinesischen
das also mehr Symbole geht nicht dass
wir zusammen aber ich würde das nicht so
negativ sehen natürlich das war ja mein
Punkt dass das Timing im Moment sehr
kritisch ist und in jeder Hinsicht aber
sie kommt eben auch mit seinem zwölf
Punkteplan ich würde ihn auch nicht als
Friedensplan bezeichnen aber dann
enthalten ist das Prinzip der
territorialen Integrität was ja der
Ukraine sehr wichtig ist sie lensky hat
diesen Plan nicht runter aus abgelehnt
und wenn man jetzt die Weichen falsch
stellt und da habe ich ein bisschen die
Sorge dass das passieren könnte und sich
diesen Gedanken die möglicherweise aus
Moskau und dann Peking kommen von vorne
rein verschließt dann geht man nicht nur
in Richtung einer Blockbildung sondern
möglicherweise wirklich eine
Konfrontation zweier Blöcke die wir
eigentlich so nicht haben wollen
eigentlich nicht das ist eine sehr große
massive Unterstützung für Putin gibt
ich glaube es nicht nein ich glaube sie
können sich allerdings nicht erlauben
und dass wir das Schreckenszenario das
Russland verliert das heißt nicht dass
sie es unterstützen müssen jetzt aber
wenn wenn Russland verliert dann ist USA
der große Gewinner auf der Weltbühne
der systemkampf sozusagen ist für den
Westen entschieden deswegen ist das
glaube ich also eher
er kann Russland nicht offen
unterstützen er möchte es auch nicht hat
Angst vor dass der Handelsbeziehungen
zum Westen Einbrechen der
Technologietransfer ist schon betroffen
das ist ein schwieriges Kalkül ich
glaube man kann nicht einseitig sagen es
gibt genug Menschen auch in Deutschland
die Angst haben vor einer Eskalation und
wenn man dann jetzt sieht
internationaler Strafgerichtshof vier
fragt auch jemand bei Twitter Herr der
Frau wie soll man mit einer Person Putin
verhandeln gegen den ein internationaler
Strafbefehl besteht also die Sache dann
Finnland also so nah an der Grenze also
ein großes Land nah an der Grenze zu
Russland wird jetzt NATO Mitglied die
Lieferung von Kampfjet diese Nachrichten
es gibt eine Menge Menschen die sagen
das könnte doch auch zu einer wirklich
starken Eskalation führen und sich da
vor eben sehr sorgen aber die
sdneskalationsdruck den haben wir ja im
Grunde genommen seit Beginn der der
völkerrechtlich
schrecklichen Invasionen der Ukraine und
wir haben nicht gesehen dass der
russische Staatspräsident also diese in
diese Momente der möglichen Eskalation
die haben schon öfter ausgemacht und wir
haben nicht gesehen ist in kamen keine
Chemiewaffen ins Spiel kam keine
biologischen Waffen ins Spiel das ganze
Land ist für mich da sind schreckliche
Dinge passiert aber zumindest ich glaube
wir können langsam etwas zurücktreten
von den den Ängsten was die nukleare
Option angeht weil wir einfach und
kontarenko hat das gesagt selbst wenn es
ein nuklearen Anschlag auf die Ukraine
geben würde denn so weit würde der
russische Staatspräsident nicht gehen
nahtoderatorium anzugreifen besonders
nicht mit einer Nuklearwaffe wäre die
Ukraine trotzdem dazu bereit weiterhin
Land und Territorium Menschen zu ver
tätigen also ich glaube wir müssen
angesichts des schiebesuchs noch mal
ganz genau kritisch schauen welche
Interessen verfolgt China was eint die
beiden natürlich der
Freundschaftsvertrag des 7 Februar wo es
eine no limits Partnerschaft gibt es ist
für China sehr lukrativ gewesen Russland
jetzt zu unterstützen Russlands
Wirtschaft kommt allein deshalb gut
durch die Sanktionen weil China Iran die
Türkei andere Länder weiterhin Russland
wirtschaftlich unterstützen mit einem
möglichen Wirtschaftswachstum für die
Russische Föderation von 2,3 Prozent das
ist
beziehungsweise umgekehrt einen Einbruch
den wir uns um die 2,3 % erdacht haben
und jetzt scheint die russische
Volkswirtschaft wieder zu wachsen und
das liegt allein darin dass Russland es
schafft eine Koalition für sich zu
schaffen aber ich stimme Herrn bonser
und Herrn zu China braucht eine
weltwirtschaftliche Stabilität auch zu
Hause sieht es für Herren schienen nicht
ganz so harmonisch aus wie er das
vielleicht bräuchte auch wenn er gerade
neue Wirtschaftspläne und großen
Wirtschaftswachstum um die fünf Prozent
versprochen hat das heißt er braucht
Stabilität und er muss sich genau
anschauen wie weit und wir wissen das
elfte Sanktionspaket wird eben auch um
sanktionsverletzer gehen wie weit er das
Ausreizen möchte und welche Folgen ist
dann für ihn in der Welt geben könnte
aber das Ziel Russland und China eint
ganz klar eine autoritäre Weltordnung
hinzubauen europäischen Interesse dass
wir einen Chinesisch russischen Block
bekommen ich würde sagen nein das ist
nicht unser Interesse wir müssen
versuchen
zu verhindern dass wir sozusagen
Russland in die Arme Chinas treiben wir
müssen versuchen zu verhindern dass es
so eine Abkoppelung kommt wie die wie
die USA sie offenbar vorbereiten wir
haben gesehen es gab dieses August
treffen
rund um Australien es sollen ähm Atom
getrieben U-Boote geliefert werden Frau
von der Leyen hat sich mit US-Präsident
beiden getroffen über China gesprochen
jetzt spricht der Kanzler in Japan über
China es geht in eine ganz gefährliche
Richtung
es geht in die gefährliche Richtung
einer massiven Blockbildung wo die
europäischen Interessen und das sind ja
nicht nur die Interessen der Ukraine wir
haben auch Wirtschaftsinteressen
Handelsinteressen und so weiter und so
fort wir haben die USA mit China ja auch
aber längst nicht in diesem Ausmaße für
Deutschland ist China der wichtigste
Handelspartner vor den USA also ich
finde wir müssen da aufpassen und wir
sollten auch Herrn Ski die Chance geben
erstmal seine Vorschläge zu machen in
Ruhe abwarten ob da nicht auch was dabei
ist was auch Europa und der Ukraine
möglicherweise voranbringen das wäre
meine Frage ob es auch der Ukraine hilft
ist ja die Frage ob sie vielleicht sogar
selenski treffen möchte den ukrainischen
Präsidenten also wie wie viel Hoffnung
haben sie auf diese Gespräche in Moskau
also ich habe gemischte Gefühle genauso
viele in der Ukraine aber auch hier im
Westen vor diesem Besuch einerseits
China hätte längst diesen Krieg stoppen
können es ist nicht passiert ich glaube
ich widersprechen ich glaube dass diese
Allianz zwischen Moskau und picking
längst Realität ist
wie stark Sie ausgeprägt ist welche
Rolle da noch Wirtschaft spielen könnte
um China zu sozusagen auf Distanz zu
Russland zu halten und das weiß ich
nicht aber ich sehe ganz deutliche
Signale diplomatische Signale und eine
klare Entwicklung
zu diesem Plan den sie erwähnt haben den
China auch auf der Münchner
Sicherheitskonferenz präsentiert hat
oder kurz davor
es gibt in diesem Plan keine einzige
Erwähnung was mit den besetzten Gebieten
passieren soll und das ist der Kernpunkt
das wird einfach ausgelassen das ist das
Thema für Verhandlung ja genau
natürlich aber irgendwas vorzuschlagen
wäre schon nicht schlecht zu Beginn und
außerdem wird da auch eine Aufhebung von
Sanktionen gefordert und die Ukraine und
der Westen haben klar gesagt Sanktion
wird es nur geben wenn Russland
Ukrainisch besetzte Gebiete wieder
freigegeben gibt es sieht überhaupt
nicht danach aus momentan deshalb bin
ich da sehr skeptisch und sie lernt in
dieser Besuch von Putin auf der Krim und
auch immer mario hat das ja noch mal
deutlich gezogen diese diese zeitliche
Nähe und das hat es noch mal deutlich
gemacht und ich glaube nicht dass das da
jetzt ein Durchbruch bevorsteht selensky
hat ja ganz klar gesagt vor einigen
Wochen dass er sich gerne mit Ski
treffen würde es gab keine Antwort
darauf aus China es heißt jetzt sie
könnten vielleicht telefonieren aber es
gibt noch keine bestätigte Nachricht
vielleicht habe ich etwas übersehen dass
er nach Kiew kommt anders als beiden zum
Beispiel
und
generell würde ich sagen von diesem
Friedensplan diese 12 Punkte die da die
Republik geworden sind dass wir den hat
an eine Art Minz 3 das heißt Konflikt
einfrieren mit Minsk 2 und 1 hatte die
Ukraine ganz schlechte Erfahrungen
gemacht russland hat diese Pause genutzt
um sich aufzurüsten und deshalb wenn die
Ukraine sich darauf einlässt auf
Gespräche was vielleicht doch Sinn
machen würde also Diplomatie macht immer
Sinn und sie findet auch statt nur bis
jetzt mit wenig Ergebnissen ja wir haben
nur diesen Getreide Deal der jetzt
verlängert wurde und das alles aber nur
zwei Sätze dazu ich glaube die Ukraine
könnte sich auf Diplomatie einlassen und
die zwei Bedingungen
die Ukraine braucht Sicherheitsgarantie
eine Sicherheitsgarantie wäre schneller
nacharbeitet davon ist nicht auszugehen
zweite Sicherheitsgarantie wäre
schneller Waffenlieferungen aber anders
als bisher das heißt moderne starke
Waffen in großem Umfang das heißt
diesen Waffen die Frontlinie halten kann
und das ist das ist ein weiterer
Problempunkt
politischen Willen zum Beispiel
Langstreckenwaffen zu liefern für die
heimatsysteme aus den USA die werden zum
Beispiel eine Art Garantie das liefert
Washington bis jetzt nicht hier fragt
auch jemand Berthold auf Twitter die
souveräne Integrität von Staaten auf die
China pocht man China dabei wirklich die
Ukraine oder die von Russland inklusive
der angeblichen russischen Ukraine das
ist ja auch die Frage also
heißt das inklusive der besetzten
Gebiete oder nicht das wissen wir
natürlich nicht ja also ich meine zwei
Dinge zu dem was ja ganzarenko gesagt
hat und das passt dann vielleicht dazu
erstes Mal ist das minzformat auf das
wir uns ja damals eingelassen haben das
ist ja überhaupt nicht mehr also das
könnten wir insofern gar nicht mehr aus
der Schublade holen denn da haben wir im
Westen angenommen es ginge Vladimir
Putin wirklich um eine ethnische
Auseinandersetzung das jetzt also zu dem
Punkt der Fragenstellung das wissen wir
dass das nicht mehr das Kriegsziel ist
ja das Kriegsziel war für den russischen
staatsspräsidenten die Einnahme und die
Annektion im besten Fall der ganzen Welt
und die Zerstörung der Ukraine als
souveräner und eigenständiger
kultureller Staat und deswegen sind auch
diese Prozedere also so dass wenn das
wieder ins Gespräch gebracht wird man
könne mit Minz wieder anfangen und aber
selbst da merkt nie gesehen dass ein
Waffenstillstand gehalten hat von den
anderen Punkten mal ganz abzusehen ist
das kein Format was funktioniert die
Diplomatie und das ist genau richtig die
gibt es weiterhin die ist natürlich um
den Getreide Deal aber auch da mussten
wir heute noch mal erfahren wie lange
soll er denn nun verlängert werden 60
Tage sowie Vladimir Putin das gerne
hätte oder unter 20 Tage wie die
internationale Gemeinschaft des möchte
und Herr Putin wirft auch immer da
wieder in die Waagschale dass wir doch
dann bitte Sanktionen lockern könnten
für russische Getreideexporte und für
russische düngemittelexporte und und und
und also wir sehen an keiner Stelle das
Russland sich in irgendeiner Weise als
verlässlicher Partner und Partner werden
natürlich zu viel gesagt sondern einfach
Gesprächs äh äh gegenüber genau
anbieten würde und das haben wir
nirgendwo gesehen das heißt auch selbst
beim Gefangenen Austausch und es gibt
informelle Kontakte zwischen dem
ukrainischen und dem russischen Militär
wir kommen da nicht weiter generell ist
aber das sind solche Vorläufer natürlich
schauen wir uns an wie der Koreakrieg
beendet hat und und und Vorläufer zu
einer größeren diplomatischen Offerte
aber selbst in diesen kleineren Formaten
zeigt sich Russland in keiner Weise als
und trotzdem also sie ist mit dem
Gespräch mit dem getreideabkommen war so
eine der vielen Nachrichten in dieser
Woche wo man dachte etwas Positives
zumindest dass man sagt auch eine und da
hat ja die Türkei dann auch eine Rolle
gespielt und hat in einer Phase
Ansprache dann dann verkündet Herr
lohndeen wie sehen Sie das also da wo
sie wo sehen sie Hoffnungen für oder
beginnen von möglichen Verhandlungen
Diplomatie als sehen sie irgendwo da
noch eine Chance wenig Hoffnung muss ich
sagen also ich glaube man muss sich
vielleicht von den Vorstellungen
vielleicht auch den Wunsch denken lösen
dass wir jetzt einen
Frieden bekommen wie wir das tatsächlich
normalerweise verstehen vielleicht
werden wir etwas
hybrides bekommen dazwischen eine Lösung
mit einem vielleicht sie haben sie auch
erwähnt ein eventuell ein Rumpf Ukraine
ich weiß dass es
spricht man nicht gerne
mit Sicherheit Garantien das Ganze für
süß
und in den anderen Gebieten bleiben
würden
welche Gebiet ist genau gehen wird ich
glaube ist oder glaube ich zu meinem man
könnte
Johannes
erobern
militärisch sondern es wird irgendwo
sich eine Linie etablieren
wo man das Land teilt auch bin ich bin
ich von überzeugt und dass wir werden
damit leben müssen so hat es es gibt
viele dieser gefrorene Konflikte in
Europa
natürlich dem nicht zustimmen das ist
klar aber auch der Westen nicht glaube
ich das könnte eine Zwischenlösung sein
das was Sie beschreiben diese Teilung es
wird nicht zementiert wie in Süd- und
Nordkorea dafür ist die Grenze viel zu
weit also in Korea ist es deutlich
kleiner diese Abschnitt wo die beiden
Länder dann aufeinander treffen die sind
die militärreisen Sohn kann man in der
Ukraine machen aber es ist sehr
schwierig durchzusetzen und Ukraine
würden sich auf aus meiner Sicht ähm
irgendwelche Verhandlungen diplomit die
nur einlassen wenn er sicher sein kann
dass es keine weiteren Gebiete verliert
in einem oder zwei Jahre denn die
Erfahrung wie gesagt bis jetzt war das
Russland diese Zeit nutzt um zu
mobilisieren um die
die Munition nach zu produzieren was
jetzt passiert und Russland haben
russland hat jetzt nicht genug die
Ukraine auch beide Seiten habe jetzt
nicht genug Munition
es gibt keine Sicherheit ja natürlich
also ich denke es wäre im besten
Interesse auch der Ukraine sich
zumindestens Gedanken zu machen wie eine
Verhandlungslösung aussehen könnte und
zwar jetzt das sage ich nur ich das
sagte Wolfgang Ischinger er hat es schon
erklärt er möchte eine Kontaktgruppe
kommen der sagt das Reich der Sicherheit
genau er sagte im Tagesspiegel es reicht
nicht dass wir nur eine Kontaktgruppe
für Waffenlieferung haben in diesem
Rammstein Format wir brauchen sozusagen
ein diplomatisches Rammstein ich denke
das ist ein ganz wichtiger Punkt wir
sehen dass die Chinesen eine
diplomatische Initiative Staaten nicht
nur in Moskau sondern auch im Nahen
Osten sprich die Gespräche zwischen
Saudi Arabien und Iran wo ist Europa das
ist meine Frage die Europäische Union
war an diesem Getreide Deal wiederum
nicht beteiligt sie ist nirgendwo
diplomatisch beteiligt die Europäische
Union gibt vor und das sage ich jetzt be
etwas polemisch zugespitzt auf Seiten
der Ukraine zu stehen in Brüssel heißt
es die Ukraine muss siegen der
Ratspräsident michelle hat gerade
erklärt eine Niederlage sei keine Option
aber hat denn diese Europäische Union
jetzt frage ich auch sie hat sie denn
überhaupt die Mittel um einen Sieg der
Ukraine herbeizuführen das ist doch
offensichtliche wer ist der überhaupt
nicht ginge ohne die USA
sprecherei ohne die USA geht es nicht
aber die USA schicken sich offenbar an
sich anderswo zu engagieren als sie
Engagement in der Ukraine abzubauen und
sich mehr China zuzuwenden wir laufen da
wirklich in ein Problem hinein spätesten
Herbst sozusagen auch alle
militärspraktiken es muss jetzt was
passieren sonst Schmerzen im Herbst
kriegen wir was
Problem genau deshalb liefert der Westen
jetzt Kampfbahn verloren viel zu spät
wir brauchen eine Strategie also Lehrer
auch für unsere Wähler die er inzwischen
auch nicht mehr genau nachvollziehen
können das sehen wir langsam auch an den
Meinungsumfragen in den USA sowieso was
jetzt wirklich wie das Ziel jetzt
wirklich zu gestalten sein eine
Möglichkeit wäre natürlich wir kommen
wirklich zu einem klaren militärischen
Part man könnte jetzt vielleicht
argumentieren in bachmut ist sind wir
fast schon da zu meinen auch weil sich
das militärische materiell aufbraucht
dennoch wäre es besser wenn es in eine
Strategie eingebettet wäre wenn wir
nicht in insofern immer den Zirkus
nachspielen würden es gibt eine die
Ukraine verlangt Waffensysteme Europa
scheut sich sie gehen zu den Amerikanern
irgendwann gehen die geben die
Amerikaner nach auch wenn sie sagen die
Europäer sind doch viel näher dran und
dann beginnt der ganze Flo Zirkus von
vorne klarer wäre und man hätte sich das
auch schon zum einjährigen
traurigen jahrestag der Invasion
gewünscht dass man gesagt hätte so wir
sagen bis zum ukrainischen Sieg oder
zumindest zum Pat und das tun wir eben
mit einer verstärkten koordinierten
Inter operablen Lieferung statt heißt
was dann ja einen hat aber dann in
diesem Fall genau erstmal das
militärisch zu gewährleisten was die
Ukraine braucht so dass zumindest die
Russland nicht weiter vordringen kann
also das was wir jetzt in Mahmut und in
den umliegenden Regionen sehen dass ich
das irgendwie so verfestigt dass das
Russland dazu zwingen würde sich
gegebenenfalls an einen
Verhandlungstisch zu setzen und ich
möchte noch mal darauf hinweisen dass
der zehn Punkteplan von Herrn selinski
sehr wohl quasi eine sequenzierte Art
und Weise der Diplomatie vorschlägt denn
er legt er der erste Punkt ist
sicherheitsringe um die
Nuklearanlagen also es geht erst Nummer
5 in diesem Friedensvertrag da geht's
dann um territoriale Integrität das
heißt der Russe der ukrainische
Präsident hat sich sehr wohl über
sequenzierte Diplomatik Gedanken gemacht
und das könnte man zusammen denken indem
man eine europäische Strategie jetzt
formuliert die Europäer müssen ganz klar
die Kommission muss ganz klar dazu
kommen dass sie auch quasi ihr eigenes
Budget für gerade für
munitionsproduktion also nicht nur durch
die friedensverilität das Nachteil
sondern eine Vorlage geht und dann diese
patzsituation zu erzeugen um zu einem
haltbaren Waffenstillstand zu kommen und
dann mit dem zehn Punkteplan
ganz kurz nur auf dem EU-Gipfel wird es
um 3,5 Milliarden Euro gehen für
Arterien und Munition im Kaliber 155 das
ist alles ich meine damit lässt sich
kein Krieg gewinnen und man behauptet
gleichzeitig wir helfen der verhelfen
der Ukraine zu im Sieg das ist eine
hoffnungslose Strategie und wenn Sie das
ist keine Strategie wenn Sie es weiter
Spenden ähm heißt es sonst wenn man also
da mehr machen möchte das ist ja von der
Leyen auch mal angedacht dass man im
Grunde genommen eine Kriegswirtschaft
aufbauen muss darüber wird ja auch in
Deutschland
war
sprechen also dieser Krieg wird schon
mit der Theorie geführt und hat eine
enorme Rolle bei diesem Krieg man kann
damit diesen Krieg gewinnen auf jeden
Fall nicht nur aber vor allem mit der
teler das haben wir gesehen im Sommer
das haben wir gesehen im Herbst und
deshalb sind diese Lieferungen aus
Europa sehr wichtig und die Ukraine ist
Milliarden Euro natürlich die Ukraine
daran auch Produktion jetzt in Europa zu
starten es gab jetzt vor einigen Tagen
eine Meldung dass damit begonnen wurde
irgendwo in einem europäischen
Nachbarland und es wird weiter
fortgesetzt wichtig ist aus meiner Sicht
sich klar zu machen dass wir über eine
Friedenslösung sprechen zu einem
Zeitpunkt wobei der Seiten sich auf
Offensive vorbereiten und jetzt darüber
zu sprechen das Schwäche die Ukraine
wollen wir das wirklich äh die Ukraine
hat jetzt vom besten Waffen bekommen mit
denen der Westen auch hofft dass die
Ukraine sich in eine bessere Verhandlung
Position bringen kann wir sind noch
nicht so weit im Gegenteil bei bachmodi
Ukraine ist gerade dabei einen Staat
möglicherweise zu verlieren und noch ein
ganz kurzer Punkt zum Korea Szenario und
dass wir jetzt vor einem einigen Minuten
besprochen haben in Korea in Südkorea
stehen amerikanische Truppen und das
Land ist sehr sehr stark bewaffnet
würden Amerikaner oder Europäer in die
Ukraine schicken dann wäre die Ukraine
vielleicht bereit zu irgendwelchen
diplomatischen Gesprächen solange das
nicht der Fall ist solange die Ukraine
auf sich alleine gestellt ist glaube ich
dass die ukrainische ukrainische
Gesellschaft irgendwelchen Verhandlungen
und Zugeständnissen zustimmen wird und
letzter Punkt
wir sollen nicht vergessen oder dürfen
nicht vergessen was russlands Präsident
Putin dazu sagt und er sagt das ist die
Botschaft schon seit Monaten wir sind
nur zur Verhandlungen bereit wenn die
Ukraine die Realitäten auf dem Boden
akzeptiert das ist die Formulierung die
sie benutzen das heißt dass diese
Gebiete Creme und die vier Gebiete Teile
der Gebiete in Ost und südkraine Teil
Russland sind Russland möchte dass die
Ukraine des akzeptiert und der besten
sowieso das wird nicht passieren
Sie die ja die Aufgabe der Europäischen
Union irland hat die Ratspräsidentschaft
also wo können sie sagen in welcher
Richtung könnte man jetzt wenn wir sagen
wir sind an so einem wichtigen Punkt das
beschleunigen
ähm
Klarheit darstellen über was die Ziele
sind ich glaube das wäre das primäre
denn wir reden über Europa oder EU wir
sind uns nicht einig es gibt große große
Unterschiede sagen wir zwischen
baltischen Staaten Polen oder Frankreich
Deutschland das schattiert sich etwas ab
aber wir sind uns nicht ein ich würde
Ziele und nehmen wir den einige extrem
Stimmen aus den USA die sagen ja wir
müssen Russland besiegen Putin in die
Knie zwingen andere sprechen davon
demokrationslinie irgendwo also wir
müssen uns irgendwo einigen was sollen
die Waffen was ist das primäre Ziel ja
immer immer weiteren Waffenlieferungen
immer modern aber was passiert das
Systeme da herrscht glaube ich kein
Einigkeit wie sehr beeinflusst denn
jetzt diese Lieferungen die angekündigte
Lieferung von Kampfjets von Polen und
Slowakei die Strategie also was heißt
das dann jetzt es ist natürlich ein ein
integrierte Bestandteil der Lieferung
von Panzern
die auch durch Kampfjets unterstützt und
geschützt werden also es ist schon
irgendwas
angreifen das ist der russische
territoren Staatsgebiet
nicht anerkannt vom Westen aber von
Russland ausgesehen ist ja auch nicht
nur es ist ja nicht nur ein Land dass
das Abwehr die USA leben ist auch ab
deutschland lehnt es ab es gibt keine
gemeinsame Antwort in Brüssel im
Klartext also diese Meldungen tröpfelten
so nach und nach einen in Brüssel in der
letzten Ende letzte Woche und dann hieß
es ja sogar das hat man auch in
deutschen Nachrichten teilweise gehört
dass die Slowakei für diese Kampfjets
dann Kompensationen bekommen sollte
finanzieller Art aus Brüssel ich habe
danach gefragt dafür ist eigentlich gar
kein Topf da ist
aus den USA Material aber es ist keine
gemeinsame Strategie und ist bringt uns
natürlich auf eine schiefe Ebene was
passiert denn wenn so ein Kampfjet hat
abgeschossen wird was Unfälle gibt
ohne oder bei dieser Begegnung zwischen
der Drohne und den russischen Kampfjet
gesehen haben wir wissen jetzt warum das
der Fall war weil ein russischer
Staatspräsident on the move war sagen
wir so aber umgekehrt Unfälle können
immer wieder passieren und
natürlich wenn man hochgerüstet in
solche Situationen reingeht ist es
schwierig umgekehrt ist aber glaube ich
das was England macht nämlich anzufangen
ukrainische kampflieger auszubilden an
Neuem und modernen Geräte natürlich hat
sich die Ukraine war sie dankbar über
glaube ich die die Meldungen aus Polen
und der Slowakei aber umgekehrt sind die
mit 29 wenn ich so richtig verstehe die
aus Polen und der Slowakei kommen sogar
noch ein veraltetes Modell als das was
die Ukraine schon hatte also so richtig
viel scheint es auch nicht unbedingt zu
helfen aber grundsätzlich sind wir
wieder bei dem Punkt wenn es eine
Kontaktgruppe geben sollte nochmal zu
dem Punkt dann würde ich mir wünschen
dass das Rammstein Format wie gesagt
ganz europäisch und amerikanisch und
gegebenenfalls mit anderen Partnern und
da sind wir wieder bei der bei der Frage
welche Einwirkungen können andere
globale Akteure auf Russland haben China
haben wir kurz besprochen aber was ist
mit Indien was ist mit anderen Ländern
was wird in den Hinterzimmern besprochen
wenn ein Bundeskanzler
Indien reist also dass da eine eine
smartere und besser sequenzierte
Strategie des Westens an den Tag gelegt
muss werden muss nachdem es eine
intereuropäische interchor westliche
Einigung gibt das wäre doch für mich
wenn es eine Kontaktgruppe geben sollte
eher der aber dann wäre es ja trotzdem
wichtig wenn man weiß wo man eigentlich
hin will damit man weiß wer mit wem
darüber verhandelt Herr konstant noch
mal kurz zu dieser Sache nachdem die
Kampfjet was bedeutet das für die
Cousine
zum großen Teil aus meiner Sicht
symbolische Debatte ich verstehe die
Ängste der Menschen die sie ansprechen
weil ähnlich wie Panzer sind
Kampfflugzeuge das steht so sinnbildlich
finden Krieg ähm aber ihre Bedeutung ist
in erster Linie für die Ukraine liegt
darin dass man damit Rakete Raketen
abschießen kann moderner Raketen das
heißt man erhöht auch die Reichweite
seiner Kampfhandlungen deshalb sind sie
wichtig auch die wenn sie auch veraltet
sind das waren trotzdem Kampf jetzt die
nato-system integriert waren das heißt
sie sind fähig diese moderne Raketen zu
tragen und darum geht so Ukraine
mir ist es wichtig einen Punkt noch zu
machen und zwar
wir sollten uns alle die Frage stellen
was würde es bedeuten wenn Russland
diesen Krieg gewinnt und eine Teilung
der Ukraine wäre an sie Russlands was
würde das bedeuten für die EU für die
NATO aber auch für die Welt in welcher
Welt würden wir dann Leben wird Putin in
der Ukraine Schluss machen wir sehen in
Moldova in dem Nachbarland da könnte
etwas passieren und mal darüber ist
deutlich schwächer als die Ukraine also
es würde eine russischen Angriff kaum
standhalten diese Frage müssen wir bei
Waffenlieferungen bei allem was wir
diskutieren immer im Hinterkopf behalten
was würde ein russischer Sieg bedeuten
die Frage ist ob ein Einfrieren dieser
Situation einen Sieg wäre aus russischer
Sicht schon deswegen
gewinnen ja deswegen denke ich die
naturerweitung ist absolut essentiell ja
wenn das gibt uns etwas mehr Sicherheit
wir die Ostsee wird ein NATO mehr im
Prinzip
wir sind besser geschützt es gibt keine
Garantien das Putin nicht in zehn Jahren
wiederkommt dann sind wir aber besser
gerüstet aber ich würde gerne die Frage
nochmal ganz kurz aufgreifen ich meine
es geht um Europa es geht um eine
europäische Friedensordnung es geht
nicht nur um die Ukraine es geht wir
müssen auch künftig mit Russland leben
wir müssen uns die Frage stellen wie
soll Europa künftig stabil mit den
Nachbarn Zusammenleben und das ist eben
frappieren das hatten sie auch gesagt es
gibt keine europäische Strategie das ist
ein ganz ganz großes Manko und wir
laufen da in die Gefahr hinein dass wir
auch uns und auch die Ukraine täuschen
dass wir sagen wir schicken euch ein
wenig Munition und schaut mal das was er
damit macht aber das reicht hinten und
vorne nicht verbrauchen Formate gerne um
eine Lösung herbeizuführen die Zuschauer
zu Wort kommen lassen weil es gibt nur
eine ganze Menge Fragen eben zu unserem
Thema und damit sie auch noch ein
bisschen Zeit haben die alle zu
beantworten wird ich gerne Dieter Zill
aus Bruchsal das erste Wort geben
schönen guten Tag
Ihre Frage bitte
[Musik]
beendet sein
die ersten leopard-panzergren Schranke
die sind bestimmt aus Polen und aber sie
sind noch nicht im Einsatz soviel ich
weiß es gab keine zuverlässigen Berichte
also es gab Spekulationen dass man sie
irgendwo dabei wachmund gesehen haben
will aber keine Bestätigung aber es gibt
die Hoffnung dass sie etwas starkes
bewirken zunächst müssen die in
ausreichender Stärke da sein noch ist es
nicht der Fall auch die Briten müssen
liefern und es wurden auch andere Panzer
versprochen also es ist noch also ich
erwarte dass die zum Einsatz vielleicht
im April mal kommen aber war das
entscheidende Signal nicht wir sind zu
allem bereit jetzt das war so ein
bisschen angebruch vielleicht ja jetzt
wo hört es auf es kommen ja nicht nur
die Panzer an es kommen auch die Marder
Schützenpanzer aus Deutschland und die
Bradley ist auf der USA die sollte man
auch nicht unterschätzen und die werden
an einer größeren Zahl geliefert das
heißt geändert wenn diese all dieses
Gerät schon vor einem halben Jahr
geliefert worden wäre ja ich bin fest
davon überzeugt dass das alles zu spät
ist und ähm wenn man Waffen die man
jetzt liefert früher geliefert hätte er
hätte Russland nicht so viel Territorium
erobern können und auch mehr Material
ist ist ja eigentlich immer die Rinne
davon gewesen in Kiew dass man
mindestens 300 Kampfpanzer braucht man
bekommt jetzt vielleicht zwei Dutzend
das reicht also das ist meine Sorge das
reicht hinteren Form nicht und wir
machen uns da etwas vor ich glaube dazu
passt die Frage von Helmut Picker aus
Zerbst schönen guten Tag Herr Picker
Ihre Frage bitte meine Frage ist die hat
ja das Ziel die gesamten russischen
Truppen
[Musik]
ist das realistisch der
Generator meint das wäre nicht
realistisch und wenn das nicht
realistisch ist welchen Sinn und welches
Ziel verfolgt die Bundesregierung dann
mit der panzerlieferung
wer möchte darauf antworten wie
realistisch ist stimmt ganz kurz sagen
dass es realistisch ist aber unter
anderem Bedingungen also stand jetzt
eher nein die Ukraine hat einfach nicht
genug Waffensysteme um die Creme zurück
zu Robotern es hat möglicherweise gerade
genug um die Frontlinie zu halten aber
auch dann kann man nicht sicher sein
es ist eine Perspektive von fünf
vielleicht zehn Jahren und es wird aus
meiner Sicht keinen ähm Sieg also keine
Rückeroberung mit militärischen Mitteln
sein sondern meine Prognose ist das
Russland sich irgendwann wenn Putin
nicht mehr an der Macht ist unter
welchen Umständen auch immer das
Russland sich aus der Ukraine ähnlich
wie die Sowjetunion außer gar nichts
dann einfach abziehen wird und dass es
wird dann ein Teil einer großen
diplomatischen Lösung genauso wie damals
in Afghanistan und auch die USA und der
Westen eingebunden waren vielleicht
einen äh Aspekt dazu ich habe Herrn
Pistorius genau diese Frage gestellt er
konnte sie nicht beantworten also es
gibt offenbar in Berlin keine festle
gung was deutsche Panzer möglicherweise
auf der krönt tun können oder nicht
dann würde ich gerne begrüßen Matthias
Stress aus Berlin schönen guten Morgen
und ihre Frage bitte
ja guten morgen an die Runde
ich habe eine kurze Frage wir hatten das
ja am Anfang ihrer Runde kurz besprochen
das funktioniert und es um
internationalen Gericht wegen seiner
Verbrechen die kann mich erinnern und
das war nicht so lange her dass ein
großer östliche Jungs machen Hamburg bin
ich zu sagen auch unsere Verbrechen in
anderen Ländern begangen hat und der
international
geworden ich erinnere an den Irak ich
Erinnerungen und ähnlich wurde ich mich
mal freuen wenn man mehr das erklärt sie
meint die USA und die Frage wie wie man
wieder Internationale Gerichtshof
gegenüber den USA auftreten soll ja also
ich meine dadurch dass die USA weiterhin
den Internationalen Gerichtshof in
keiner Weise legal unterstützt würden
sich die Amerikaner auch was die Ukraine
angeht eher ein sonder tribonal wünschen
dass schwanger bei der Rede von Kamera
Harris mit das ist ein im Grunde
genommen altes Prinzip
der Amerikaner dass der Irakkrieg und
das was die USA im Irakkrieg in
Anführungszeichen auch verbrochen hat
jetzt ganz stark aufgearbeitet wird
gerade in dieser Woche zum 20 Jahrestag
das ist auch der Fall das will diese
Regierung auch machen und sich mit ihrer
eigenen Vergangenheit stark beschäftigen
aber für diese Regierung tickt auch die
Uhr und natürlich sind auch werden
werden wir keine Veränderung sehen wenn
es um die Mitgliedschaft im
Internationalen Gerichtshof geht aber
für USA gab es kein internationales
Tribunal ja natürlich das natürlich dass
die USA da ihre Machtposition ausspielt
ist ohne Frage und das schwächtige
Glaubwürdigkeit des Westens gegenüber
dem globalen Süden über dem wir
gesprochen haben wenn es also nur um
Kriegsverbrechen der Russen in der
Ukraine geht und nicht über um alles
andere das in der Welt passiert
Stichwort jedem oder was auch immer dann
wird das nicht als glaubwürdig empfunden
werden
schon seit Jahrzehnten mit dem UN-System
und anderen Organisationen auch als
Westen betreiben
wir haben noch mehrere Fragen und ich
begrüße Robert cipelius aus Nürnberg
schönen guten Tag Herr cipelius ja guten
Morgen
meine Frage haben wir nicht in Europa
gelernt dass es nur dann Frieden ist
wenn man den Menschen in Europa hat
viele Gebiete gegeben wo man nicht weiß
wohin die Gehirn wenn man den Menschen
mit dran beteiligt wenn man die Menschen
im donpass beträgt und auf der Krimi wo
die den leben wollen als Endpunkt dieser
ganzen Auseinandersetzung der sagte pro
Putin bin oder gegen die Ukraine aber im
schlimmsten Fall hätten wir vielleicht
den Krieg so gewonnen dass die Ukraine
die Gebiete wieder hat aber die Menschen
doch lieber in Russland leben wollen und
dann werde ich so viel Musik
was sagen sie dazu ich sage das wird als
eine Möglichkeit Zwischenlösung
diskutiert dass man da die Menschen
befragt aber um so ein Referendum
durchzuführen müssen zwei Bedingungen
erfüllt sein die russischen Besatzung
müssen sich zurück und das Gebiet muss
ohne Verwaltung kommen und zwar nicht
für ein Jahr sondern für drei vier fünf
Jahre vielleicht das ist auch da und all
die geflüchteten die dann schon seit
2014 dann was verlassen haben aber auch
Menschen auf der krimik sehr da
überhaupt keinen Unterschied zwischen
der Situation und dornbas die müssen
alle zurückkehren können und an dieser
Uhr an diesem Referendum dann diese
Befragung teilnehmen das wäre vielleicht
ein gangbarer Weg aber es ist nicht das
was Putin anstrengen denke ich und ein
Punkt den wir da nicht vergessen dürfen
das ist auch ein Vorschlag von Thomas
Pickering an sehr seniorigen
amerikanischen ähm Diplomaten aber was
wir da nicht vergessen müssen ist eine
Information
ja Situationen hat sich ja komplett
verändert wir sehen einen russischen
Staat der zu massiver des Information
zuständig oder der die Möglichkeiten
massiver des informationsstrategisch
nutzt und umgekehrt also selbst wenn wir
drei bis fünf Jahre eine Situation eine
Beruhigung an den Tag legen würden wenn
sie dann immer noch um die Temperatur
und die Herzen der Menschen vor Ort
gehen und da hat Russland ganz ganz
klare strategische Vorteile in der
strategischen Kommunikation die würden
sie bis ans Ende ausspielen und wir
haben ja auch bei den Abstimmungen in
den besetzen Gebieten gesehen dass im
Zweifel Russland dann doch eine Methode
findet Waffen Desinformation Dinge für
sich zu drehen oder nicht ein großer
Punkt dazu warum ist schwierig sein
könnte Russland betreibt seit 2014 ganz
gezielt eine
bevölkerungsstrukturveränderung das
haben wir auf der Krim gesehen wo massiv
Leute aus Russland dahin geschickt
wurden und wir sehen auch diese gezielte
Veränderungen auch jetzt im Dornbach
oder in den besetzten Gebieten das heißt
Leute aus Russland kommen dahin wir
würden sie dann in fünf Jahren abstimmen
angenommen in diesem theoretischen
Szenario natürlich werden sie für
Russland stimmen und das ist auch dafür
müsste dann eine Lösung gefunden werden
das ist ein Problem die Lösung haben wir
hätten wir seit 2014 vielleicht nicht
finden aber vorantreiben können ich
denke das sind auch die Fehler der
Vergangenheit die sich jetzt rächen
wobei der Seiten denke ich wie eine mehr
bestimmt haben
vielen Dank dafür der nächste Anrufer
ist Michael Schal aus Kaiserslautern
schönen guten Tag und ihre Frage
ja schönen guten Tag in ihrer Hunde
meine Frage bezieht mich auch was mit
Abkommen und zwar hat der Kollege aus
von der Deutschen Welle das Abkommen
abgesprochen meine Frage ist
Holland und merkt euch zwei Teilnehmer
des Abkommens haben dezidiert verlaufen
lassen das sie mit dem Unterschrift des
Menschen bekommens der Ukraine zeigt
gewähren wollten um aufzurissen dies ist
aber es gibt ja im Geschäft keine
mächtige Aufmerksamkeit der USA von 5
Milliarden Dollar das gleiche meine
Frage wird hier nicht
geschichtreibungen geklettert indem man
sagt Russland der Polizei auch groß
genug zum aufrunden
sie sagen die NATO hätte die Zeit gehabt
um in der Ukraine aufzurüsten das ist
jetzt richtig ich glaube der Punkt ist
dass das ist auch ein narrativ
russischer Propaganda wo dann Merkels
Worte umgedreht werden oder Allans
wollte dass man da Ukraine Zeit geben
wollte natürlich mal wollte man da
Ukraine Zeit geben aber
inwiefern Deutschland hat keine Waffen
geliefert hat sich bis zum Schluss bis
zum 22
24 Februar keine Waffen geliefert die
USA haben bis 2018 keine Waffen
geliefert das heißt und auch danach
unter Trump hat man nur die Javelin äh
panzerbrechende Raketen geliefert also
ganz einfache Waffen die für ein
Partisanenkrieg vielleicht ein aber
nicht für Rückeroberung der Gebiete von
der Ukraine gab es im Gegenteil es gab
Zugeständnis an silencekern die Macht
kam 2019 da hat er Zugeständnisse
gemacht die sein Vorgänger poroschenko
nicht gemacht hat es gab ein Flechtung
sogenannte Entflechtung an einigen
Stellen als Pilotprojekte sozusagen
wo tatsächlich man sehen konnte das
könnte funktionieren aber dann hat Putin
das Gegenteil getrieben ja und und diese
ganze Zeit das unterschätzen wir er hat
im Grunde genommen seit
2013/2014 einen großen Krieg vorbereitet
er hat
2016/2017 sein Land massiv getestet alle
Systeme wurden getestet die Banken das
Internet für einen großen Krieg wie
jetzt die Waffenproduktion wurde
angekurbelt der Begriff Produktion
werden Kriegszeit wurde eingeführt das
war alles während das also wer wenn ein
Land diese Pause genutzt hat dann war
das eher Russland als die Ukraine links
zur Wahrheit gehört auch das weder die
EU noch die USA die minskraft kommen
wirklich unterstützt haben also das
waren Deutschland und Frankreich die
sich da zeitweise engagiert haben am
Ende ja auch nicht mehr die Europäische
Union hat das immer verbal zwar
befürwortet aber nichts dafür getan mit
USA haben zum Teil dagegen gearbeitet
wird gerne nicht mehr so viel Sendezeit
haben noch mal ein zwei Zuschauer zu
Wort kommen lassen nämlich
aus Berlin schön guten Tag Herr
wissenski Ihre Frage bitte
mit der Türkei kann man die aussenator
ausschließen und wenn ja wäre das eine
zu starke Schwächung
angesichts ihrer Erpressungsversuche
meinen sie sozusagen die Richtung
Schweden und wie würden Sie das sehen
sie nicht ausschließen genauso wie es
Einstimmigkeit bei der Aufnahme braucht
wir dann Ausschluss
in Türkei spielt eine ganz zentrale
Rolle geopolitisch aber auch
militärische zweitgrößte Militär macht
in der NATO oder Armee in einem also
Landstreitkräfte in der Jona liegt
strategisch extrem zentral mit Grenzen
an Jahren Syrien
Georgien also bei can also mitten in
diesen ganzen spannungsgebiet und ist
irgendwie eine Drehscheibe für Energie
Lieferungen aus dem Kaspischen Meer über
die Türkei also ist schwierig ohne
Türkei zu Recht zu kommen in dieser sehr
doch unruhigen Regierung aber trotzdem
wie wird Schweden denn sich jetzt weiter
verhalten also wenn Schweden sagt wir
müssen diese NATO Mitgliedschaft
brauchen
Sie dann wird es sehr viel Geschichte
vor uns sonst NATO gibt für den Vilnius
11 juli
also bis dahin muss man sich dann da
noch passiert gar nichts okay dann würde
ich dann eine letzte Frage haben wir
noch sind so viele Männer zu Wort
gekommen dann gebe ich das Wort mal an
Ingrid war zehn aus Bochum schönen guten
Tag Frau Bochum Frau ziehen
die nur als reines ukrainisches Problem
angesprochen wurde und jetzt weiß man
aber dass ein Einsatz selbst von unter
1%, das machen Potenzials das ist auf
der Welt gibt zu einem massiven
nuklearen Winter mit massiven
Hungersnöten führen wird nach Stuhl nach
Studien der NASA und der hat das
University
wie stehen Sie zu dieser
eskalationsmöglichkeit und welche
welche Maßnahmen sehen sie vor
also Auswirkungen wird er würde ein
Nuklearschlag selbst auf das Territorium
der Ukraine in jedem Fall auch auf
Europa haben ich meine wir denken alle
an 1986 und Tschernobyl und da war es
eben ein ein Unfall der ungesteuert war
hier wird es um eine Steuerung gehen
also das ist mit jedem Fall auch
wirklich ganz physische Auswirkungen auf
Europa haben könnte aber noch mal die
Frage was steht dann dahinter denn also
für für ein Herrn Putin würde ist dann
natürlich umgekehrt trotzdem deutlich
ernster werden weil dann muss die NATO
in irgendeiner Weise reagieren wenn es
nicht nahtoderatorium ist da erzählt
natürlich weiterhin das Prinzip der
nutelly should desstruction das heißt
ein Auge gegen ein Auge in
Anführungszeichen aber hier wäre
natürlich eine dezidiertere Reaktion
aber dennoch eine kraftvolle Reaktion
gefragt und umgekehrt kann ich mir nicht
vorstellen und der contarenko wird es
besser einschätzen kann wie das in
irgendeiner Weise die Ukraine davon
abhalten würde dann nicht weiterhin
dagegen zu halten und sich dann in
Anführungszeichen noch mehr aber wie
besorgt ist man in der Ukraine vor
diesem vor einem möglichen Atomschlag es
gab eine Zeit im Frühling 22 da war man
sehr besorgt da kann man irgendwie
besonders starke Drohungen aus Russland
danach hat es nachgelassen ich
persönlich glaube nicht dass Russland
das machen würde also taktische
Atomwaffen in der Ukraine einsetzen es
macht auch wenig Sinn militärisch es
macht wenig Sinn dass also kieft damit
anzugreifen dafür ist die Stadt viel zu
wichtig das ist ein Heiligtum für die
orthodoxe Kirche im Süden der Ukraine
macht es wenig Sinn weil dann die Krähen
und die besetzten Gebiete betroffen
werden im Norden ist Belarus zu nah also
das heißt wenn überhaupt dann irgendwo
im Westen Richtung Polen vielleicht aber
auch da macht es wenig Sinn militärisch
das wäre eine Symbolik und die die
Konsequenzen die Reaktion des Westens
wäre dann dann würde der besten aus
meiner Sicht alles liefern wünscht und
dann ist der Krieg verloren
ausschließen würde ich das nicht also
die Amerikaner haben gesagt in diesem
Fall weil Einsatz taktischer Sachen
würde die Ukraine die russische Armee in
der Ukraine vernichtet genau das wurde
sehr klar kommuniziert welche Konsequenz
sind das jetzt NATO baut und die USA
bauen auch diese tropolisse auf also es
wird weiter massiv ausgerüstet und das
ist ein bisschen meine Sorge dass wir in
ein solches Szenario kommen können wir
hoffen mal vielleicht dass der Besuch
von diesem Maske irgendeine positive
Nachricht findet in dieser Woche und
dass wir überhaupt etwas positive
Nachrichten über diesen schrecklichen
Krieg mal vermelden können vielen Dank
für die Diskussion hier im Studio und
vielen dank ihnen fürs zuschauen Ihnen
noch einen schönen Sonntag bis dann
tschüss
[Musik]
der Finanzminister hat die Faxen dick
die Spendierhosen an den Beinen der
bundesministerinnen und Minister bläht
sich immer mehr auf angemeldeter mehr
Bedarf im Bundeshaushalt 2024 70
Milliarden Euro jetzt will es nicht
Christian Lindner seine
kabinettskolleginnen und Kollegen
einzeln vorknöpfen die zeigen sich
bislang